♪ [music] ♪
Having dealt with cash and cross-holdings,
we have a few more loose ends to tie up.
So let's bring in the remaining loose ends
that'll allow you to get to the value
of equity per share in your company.
Let's finish our discussion
of cross-holdings first.
In most companies, doing the value
of the cross holdings right
which requires the full financial
statements of the parent company
and the subsidiaries is going
to be almost impossible to do.
Why? Because many companies
don't reveal the details you need
about their cross-holdings
to value them right.
So here are two compromise
solutions you can adopt.
If your company has a cross-holding
in another publicly traded company,
you could take the market value
of that publicly traded company
and use that to estimate the value of your
cross-holding. So let's say you own 10%
of a publicly traded company with a market
value of a billion. Ten percent of the
billion is 100 million.
It's cheating and here's why
it's cheating. An intrinsic valuation,
which is what you're doing when you
discount cash flows at the cost of
capital, you are assuming that markets
make mistakes and that you
cannot just trust a market value.
And you're selectively ignoring that rule
when you have a cross-holding.
But if you have hundreds of cross-holdings
in public companies,
you might have no choice
but to use the market value solution.
Say what if I don't have a market value?
What if my subsidiary is not
publicly traded? Here's another cheat you
can use. You have the book value of that
cross holding, right?
In your balance sheet?
If you know what sector your cross-holding
is in, you can convert that book value
to a market value. Again,
let me give you an example.
Let's suppose you have a cross-holding
in a chemical company and that that
cross-holding is $100 million book value.
And let's say that chemical companies
typically trade at one and
a half times book value.
One and a half times
100 million is 150 million.
That becomes the estimated market
value of your crossholding.
It's an approximation
but given the information you have,
that might be as good
a number as you can get.
Now let's start to anything else you
might want to bring into your valuation.
Now remember, when you discount
cash flows back at the costed capital,
you value the operating assets.
You brought in cash,
you brought in cross-holdings.
You should be done, right?
But check around. Check around to see if
there are other assets your company owns
which you haven't counted yet.
What might that include?
Truly vacant assets.
A piece of land that the company owns.
A piece of real estate that it's not
using. Some other assets that adds value
but it's not reflected near operating
income. You might want to bring that in.
In some cases, especially in the US,
we have companies which have defined
benefit plans where essentially they
promised a fixed pension to their
employees to the extent that that benefit
plan is overfunded. You have an overfunded
pension plan, there are some
people who add on that overfunding
arguing that it belongs
to the equity investors.
But when you're counting these
other assets, just be careful.
You cannot double count.
Let me explain what I mean by double
counting. Let's assume you're valuing
an oil company. You discount the cash
flows back at the cost of capital,
you come up with the present value right?
You cannot take that present value and add
to it the value of the refineries you have
and other assets you have because those
are the assets that generate the cash
flows. Simple rule, you cannot count
an asset and the cash flows
from that asset in the same valuation.
That's double counting.
Let's do a final loose end.
You've taken into account cash,
you've looked at cross-holdings,
you've brought in any other assets a
company might have. You're almost there.
You subtract out debt from that value
for the business you have.
You should have the overall value
of equity for the company right?
Here's the final stop you have to make
to get to value of equity per share.
In the last 20 to 30 years,
in the US especially,
companies have increasingly turned
to paying their employees with equity.
Equity in one of two forms,
options and restricted stock.
Restricted stock, you don't have
a problem. Restricted stock show up in the
outstanding shares, they're already dealt
with. But when a company grants options,
it creates a problem in discounted cash
flow valuation because it creates a second
claim on your equity.
What do I mean by second claim?
The overall value that you get for your
equity now is claimed by two groups,
one is the common stock holders through
their ownership of shares and one is
by managers through their ownership
of options. You have to net out the value
of that second claim if you want the value
per share as a common stockholder.
Incidentally, the way you have to deal
with equity options granted to employees
varies depending on whether you're looking
at options that have already been granted
or whether there are options that you
expect to be granted in the future and
let's lay out the rules on how to deal
with each of these types of options.
To the extent that you have options
already outstanding and US companies
report these in their financial
statements, here's what you have to do.
Value the equity as if there were
no options. So take the cash flows,
discount them back at the costed capital,
do everything you have to do to get to the
value of equity. Then value the equity
options as options. You're saying,
"What does that mean?"
Don't value them based on the exercise
value today. An option has a time premium.
Value these options using an option
pricing model. Then subtract out the value
of these equity options from the value
of your equity and then divide
that remaining value by the actual
shares outstanding. You don't have
to adjust for the delusion because you
effectively reflected the delusion
in the value of equity options subtracted
out from the value of equity. This
is the right way to deal with options
outstanding rather than trying to adjust
the number of shares for options that
might be exercised in the future.
Value the equity, subtract out the value
of equity options, divide by the
number of shares. You're saying,
"What about options that might be granted
in the future?" Remember why companies use
options to compensate employees.
It's because they don't have the cash
to play their employees.
Treat it like any other
compensation expense. What does
that mean? If you treat it as an expense
in the future, it's going to reduce your
operating income and reduce your future
cash flows. By reducing your future cash
flows, it's going to reduce the value
of equity. It might sound like
double counting but it's not,
because it's reading two
separate claims on the equity.
The first, we value the options and
subtract them from the value of equity,
takes care of past option grants.
The second, we take into account the
options in the future and
reduce future cash flows,
take into account future options issues.
They both can hurt your value as
an equity investor in the company.
So to the extent that you've
followed along up to this point,
you're ready to come up with a value
of equity per share of your company.
So assuming you've added the cash
and you've brought in cross-holdings
into your valuation, here
are the final two steps.
Check around for any other assets
you might have as a company.
To the extent that these assets haven't
been counted, make sure you're not
double counting, add them on. Then
subtract out the debt and if you have
equity options, take care of them now.
Take care of them right by valuing them
as options. You're ready. You can
come up with the value of equity
per share. That is your intrinsic value
for the equity per share in this company.
♪ [music] ♪